[Music]
the days are getting colder
shorter
darker this is my favorite time of
year this is also the time of year I
usually begin heading south to warmer
weather to familiar places to coastlines
and
desert a slow Meander down the Oregon
and California coast then eventually
over to Arizona Nevada New Mexico until
the weather warm STS just enough to
travel through Utah and the canyon
[Music]
lands until spring gives way to Summer
and suddenly there are too many places
to choose
[Music]
from
for 4 years I followed this predictable
pattern of winter
migration and then last
winter I did something
different
[Music]
I spent the CER months in the Pacific
Northwest fully embracing The Moody
weather and the endless rain it wasn't
supposed to start raining for another
three hours so
uh
crap because I still have 3 hours to go
tonight and it is
midnight not good not
good
[Music]
Sor good
morning I went to bed at 2:30 in the
morning cuz I was trying to game plan
started raining at midnight the winds
were crazy it was definitely unsafe to
drive I was kind of sliding around I
ended up at a rest stop
and now I still have 6 hours of driving
and has not stopped raining the wind is
pretty wild and it's only supposed to
get worse so wish me luck guys that
beeping it's cuz I have that spare tire
on the back so it thinks something is
behind me at all times whenever I'm
reversing that's my
radio oh my God I can't see
anything
the long nights and gray days to me felt
like a form of unspoken permission to
unwind rest and
recharge oh yeah very uneven I'm kind of
a EV when it comes to having my van flat
we need to lift this side and especially
the front so we're going to need stacks
on
Stacks I felt like I finally had the
time and space to
wander without the self impose pressure
of making the most of good
weather or the need to be doing
something all the time this is one thing
I genuinely love about having my van is
in between shooting I can just run back
home and grab a
snack import my
footage maybe watch YouTube video like I
can do whatever and
then just run back out and shoot like
I'm already
here honestly it's almost hard to
imagine not having my entire house with
me at all times like if I roll up to a
place to meet friends and it's a little
bit chillier than I thought it would be
no big deal my entire closet's with me
so I'm just like hold on one sec and I
go change and I've gotten so used to
that kind of spoiled in a way that I
have like a
mild I don't know what you would call it
but I'm just like oh my gosh what do I
bring with me what do I put in my purse
what do I put in my backpack I just want
to be able to have access to everything
at all times I'm like a turtle that's
what I am I'm like I'm like a turtle
this is my shell and it's hard to
imagine not having it if that makes any
sense I'm going to go ahead and import
my files really quick and then go catch
Sunset because I think it's going to pop
off uh there's some clouds and I think
we're going to get some nice
pastels so came and it went too
soon F The Sting of the winter
BL lost the Sun and I lost the
feeling that I have something I
believe I don't know who I am this year
came so close but I'm
[Music]
no love
someone time but it feels
Ste could it be could it be I be
rning all of this time I
[Music]
don't heading south every year means
existing in a kind of Perpetual summer
and it can feel a little
disorienting over time in the constant
absence of change everything can start
to look and feel the
same
[Music]
I stayed in Long Beach Washington
walking the coastline and washing
Sunset I spent a month based near
Portland spending entire days curled up
by the
fire reading and watching the
rainfall
[Music]
I flew to Florida to see
family
[Music]
then took my time traveling south along
the Oregon coast I'm
working and I'm on whale
watch I just saw some spouts out my
window
so I got the camera set up just in
case so I can swing open the door and
hopefully catch them on the long
[Music]
LS when spring arrived I settled into
Napa Valley and the bay area for a
couple of longer pet sits
I spent nearly a month feeling grounded
reestablishing healthy routines and good
habits and then the summer came around
and things kind of went
sideways my van as most of you know
became unlivable my trip overseas was
cut short and suddenly I was in over my
head with a complete van
rebuild it was all kind of a blur to be
be honest and by the time October rolled
around I was really craving a Slowdown
what you guys do with the other
egg craving stability is nothing new
around here it's been a reoccurring
theme for a while
now there's no denying that being in one
place is healthier for me in a lot of
ways we got two eggs
today and sometimes I feel disappointed
in myself for not making a
change but then I find myself pet
sitting in yet another literal Paradise
after months of freedom on the road and
I wonder why I would ever consider
giving up my current
lifestyle I spent this fall exploring
the Rockies and the San hor
mountains and for about a week I stayed
at this incredible house on the
outskirts of Durango
looking after two Bengal
[Music]
cats it was yet another reminder that
unless I win the lottery sometime
soon I won't be able to afford a
sprawling estate with a pool a cold
plunge jacuzzi a dry sauna gym satellite
Sunset Hut and 2 miles of private hiking
trail not even
close and I find myself in what has now
become a very familiar cycle of
questioning why pour my life savings
into something basic and choose one
single place when I can travel and look
after other people's beautiful
homes especially wants to come with cute
[Music]
pets
I ran up to this Sunset spot it's
absolutely
incredible it's called the Sunset Hut
and it's on this property that I'm hous
sitting for and I came up here to drone
but naturally I forgot my
controller
so just got to enjoy the
sunset this is a cycle I get stuck in
often I burn out on the road and think
about getting getting a
place I weigh the pros and cons of both
buying and
renting then I spend hours researching
where I might want to live because I
still don't know and then I crunch the
numbers of Van life versus paying a
mortgage versus paying rent and every
time at least so far I decide that if I
can just continue with my current
lifestyle I'll keep saving money and
then I can hopefully afford something in
a place I really
love the thing I can't quite get behind
to be completely
transparent is the thought of having a
mortgage to me debt feels like the
opposite of
Freedom the last time I was in debt was
in 2014 when I finally paid off my
college loans and for better or worse
I've just grown up accustomed to the
relative Financial Freedom of living
with
less in my case that means having no
place to call home but it also means
getting to do all the things I
love that said travel isn't the only
thing I
love I do miss having a place of my own
and the stability that comes with
it I don't know if it's just a phase or
the longer nights and darker
days but something does need to change
even if only for a
season or maybe for
good I'm still trying to figure it
out and over the past few months I've
started to explore what that change
might
be
[Music]
earlier this year my family and I
started chatting about a place my
grandparents bought over 30 years ago
64 acres of land in the
Ozarks they eventually built it out to
include a small network of cabins and a
large two-story main
cabin it's been mostly abandoned for the
past 10 years with only a few visits
here and
there we found the plot of land on
Google Maps and it was mostly tree cover
but in one small section some something
bright peaked through and when we zoomed
in we realized it was the roofing of one
of the
cabins and in an instant I just
knew I had to go
there so that's what I
[Music]
did
w
[Music]
I'm a Chihuahua Auntie
FAO I can't edit like
this you're right on my tablet